i did preston and steve you know uh in
philadelphia number one i'm gonna go see
those
great guys and they go you and grillo
man you and girl i just feel like you
guys are such
man's men such guys guys and it's so
rare
and i go i go i don't think i'm a guy's
guy i i don't know who you've been
hanging around
but like i i don't put myself in your
category i was like i don't think they
were like talking about how macho i am
what a guy's guy i was like i'm just not
i don't know where this is when i tell
you when people are talking about tough
guys in hollywood i'm like friends and
then
yeah and i said no frank yeah well frank
punch in the face and then you go and
then you go and travel around the world
with guys who do it for a living and you
like i said you see these guys
sparring with four ounce gloves and no
headgear
and their fight they're sparring as if
they're in a fight as if dana white's
there was like hey we're going to give
you a contract
dude yeah i've never seen the culture
it's like but that's the way
and they're still that that's like you
know that shoot box that
right right they just never adapt from
that a lot of them still struggle with
it which isn't good
yeah but they they instill this kind of
toughness in them
jackson's was like that for a while our
gym in uh
denver was like that for a while it's
funny you saw the toughest guys
i spent the afternoon at brazilian top
team i was there with them for uh
for a few hours and where nogueira came
from i mean you're talking no guy was
supposed to come down he didn't come
down but i was with you know bustamante
and those guys legends
legends man and bad bad men i mean tough
dudes yeah tough yeah yeah just
different
you you realize you're like oh i'm not
like them no you know you're like yeah
you're wrong people like hey brandon oh
i'm not like brandon you are you are
i'm not though yeah you are i'm not you
don't get it twisted look at me in the
face right now [ __ ] you are
i'm not willing and by the way and by
the way yeah
oh yeah you are and oh and one more
thing you beat those guys
so right please be quiet no it's
different i love you
i love him because he's different
culture he has an artist's heart and he
and he has that sensibility
but he also he's also a killer and elite
athletes he also i've seen
he he fought the best in the world yeah
and beat a lot yeah but it's just
different train with a lot of those guys
i know
i don't know how to describe it it's
just like something like like when i
meet crone or
thumb around hickson like i'm just like
i don't know like these guys are like
pure
jiu-jitsu but they're it's different
because they're outliers in the sense
that
these guys are born into this culture
but it's also all they care about
although that's right when i'm like
let's talk about you know
brazilian art or let's talk about
surfing or chicks or
food or like let's go talk about the me
what like why
you you didn't talk about starch chokes
and geez right here
all right that's true you didn't like
being around the fight like the
the macho you didn't like that that's
not your thing but you're you're killing
i can't take that but you're a killer
even like i have friends that are we all
do that are in special forces or you
know
seals and this and that and you know i
it's amazing to be around them because
they're the true warriors and
fearless it's good to check that world
yeah but yeah i don't want to live in
that no
yeah i shut down in that world yeah me
too it's a different animal
is it like it and it has nothing to do
with chuck liddell i love chuck liddell
but like
we're at the commie store brian and i
had sets and rogan's there and
russell peters and crystalia and then
chocolate comes in the back and then
it's this
fight culture and i'm out you run away i
went you're about to go from any fight
situation i'm out and i just went in the
back i mean rogan shot the [ __ ] with
dalia talking about i don't know
dicks or something it's fun to watch
he's so happy in that environment
like to watch you now because you've
been doing stand-up so much
killing watching [ __ ] killing you
dude he's killing it and he's around
like
the people he really wants to be around
like artists and comics right well he
was around the other thing
you know what else it is it's uh yeah
there's also no egos no ego well there
are but it's different
it's different there's no like it's not
a pissing it's not a mod show
no it's not it's different i guess when
you're ready it's all it's almost like
who can out with the others
also you are a guy who could not be more
confident with his
physical self right so when you're a guy
who's
you know you don't walk through the
world with any fear of
of other men right no you get a lot of
these other guys
that are they're doing comedy safe for a
specific reason and a lot of them are
insecure
100 and a lot of them are afraid and are
afraid of being afraid and
you don't have that vibe that's not you
you you you know i mean i was that's
funny because
when you were watching those senegalese
guys as big as they are i'll throw my
boy in there
right now in a heartbeat right now i'll
show you in there and i'll throw you
away
right now the biggest hamstrings ever
since yeah
but you've you've taken those guys and
i've seen you guys it depends what
they're doing
you put me in their environment i get
that long flight i got the food's weird
i got you i have frank tell me what to
do
i'm all stressed out i got my money on
you and you know what i do i go hey
listen
you got you bull up pull the whole [ __ ]
up
put on that i slapped their mouth a
couple of times
i i cinch up your [ __ ] girl i get the
chocolate african droplets
hanging with their tits out behind you
i'm gonna pierce both your nipples and
you go
through the nose yep and then i [ __ ]
slap you up a little bit and i
throw you out there and you do just fine
although i want to see if we can see
some of those guys i don't know how
about
strong but the top left you got some you
got some big
look at this size there look at this if
you if i get if i can get guillotines
look at this guys they can't grab is
that a car grab
there's some dick rabbit by the way by
the way stuff your [ __ ] loins because
otherwise you're gonna look like a pee
wee around those guys i feel like having
an advantage though don't get me wrong i
do well in the [ __ ] department but yeah
according to these guys
these guys big old panthers that's a
problem yeah that's a problem i'm
grabbing
you gotta grab grab that panther tail
and go to work aliens came down and
that's the first thing they saw they go
we're going back you'll [ __ ] you guys go
up go up to where those guys are
standing what they would
let let me let me see yeah get wait no
no back or
back let me let me get let me get done
let me get that now take a look take
that in
i want you to look at the sway of the
back right and the way the back
juts in in the ass juts the [ __ ] out but
but that's why when you go when we go
everyone's on pd's
well then these guys aren't you guys
aren't [ __ ] i don't know even what
they eat out there
fishing
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue okay
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespected